I'm sure I've kept it.
I've gotten used to it a lot. It
's a
word that seems to be a waste because of the teacher
's guidance. I'm going to the road from now on, but I wonder if there's anything else left.
I told him to be careful about my body,
but I'm a good person to take a break. There are times when I
'm worried about that. I heard
that you're calling Rigel today.
I don't feel
lonely because I'm the only one who can support my father as the next road,
so now I'm just a person who
works
hard at work.
Did I really lie to Glass Claire? I
can't say
I want to talk to my dad a little, but I wonder where he is now. I
saw him in the courtyard earlier, but I've erased it.
Rigel,
don't you feel like becoming a road?
[Music] I
thought I'd been doing my best without looking aside
. It's suitable for a road. Don't be embarrassed by
your father.  Choose that person
[Music]